Cameron is in Atlanta hi Cameron how are
you fine how are you David it's an honor
to speak with you you too what's up I
was wondering how do I open a franchise
and should I pay all cash for it because
I was talking with my dad and he was
recommending that I take out an SBA loan
and I just I didn't know what to do okay
well I don't recommend people take out
loans for anything especially small
business I love business I want you to
go in business if owning a business is
your dream I want you to do that I want
it to be your dream not your nightmare
and 80% of small businesses fail in the
first five years and the number one
reason they fail is cashflow problems
regarding debt and so no I would not go
in to take out an SBA loan
not a chance I wouldn't do that wouldn
tellyou out any kind of a loan so what
the problem is I only make about $80,000
a year and it's just me because I'm 25
my dad's 52 and I was just wondering you
know how do I save up the money to start
my business because I won't kind of want
to start it soon okay well you're single
and you're 25 years old you make 80
grand yes way to go thank cellent what
do you do for a living I'm a mechanical
engineer okay and what kind of a
business are you wanting to start I'm
I'm wanting to start either a Dairy
Queen or a Marco's Pizza why because I
kind of want to get into the food
service business why I don't really have
a good reason I just kind of want to
make more money okay bad reason to go in
business you need to find a business
that you want to go into that you love
the business and that you've got some
history in just listen just listen
listen listen listen it's just going
into business and make money business is
too hard
it will destroy you if you're just
trying to make money you have to have a
love for what you're doing because
you're gonna be doing so much of it I
got a buddy up here just up the street
that owns a Marco's Pizza it is a great
product I'm a customer my mouth is
watering right now okay so I'm not
against you know the idea of that and
I've been known to eat at a Dairy Queen
you know I mean I can promise you I like
ice cream so I'm not against any of that
but I listen I've been running a
business almost all my whole adult life
and it is hard and the only reason you
want to go into a business is not to
just make money don't pick out
something's you go oh I think I can make
some money doing that
dude you're 25 years old you're making
$80,000 now yeah you are making money
listen you are running towards the wall
with your foot on the accelerator and
you're gonna completely grack you've
already decided what you're gonna do
Cameron so you go do it but you're
getting ready to destroy your freakin
life if you don't slow down here son
slow down slow down I'm not gonna argue
with you
if you make a decision on based on
trying to make money and based on just
jumping out there I don't mind ambition
I want you to be ambitious I want you to
take incentive I want you to go live
your dream but you are getting ready to
jump into a mess because you got the
fever so bad you got all this figured
out in your head and it's not gonna turn
out that way there's three rules of
business it takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it costs twice as
much as you think it's going to and
you're not the exception those are the
three rules of business so you need to
enter something wisely slowly carefully
with no debt having invested and thought
about it and studied and if it takes you
two or three years to save up the money
and do your exploration
so what you're only 25 you've got time
but if you go open to Marco's Pizza and
go get you an SBA loan and go deeply in
debt 25 years old I predict you're gonna
be bankrupt before you're 30 because you
don't know what the flip you're doing
and Marco's makes great pizza and
they're gonna provide you some business
acumen but not enough to pick you up
not in your case go slow honey I don't
want you get hurt I want you to live
your dream but I don't want to be a
nightmare I'm the guy picks up the
pieces from people's lives when they
screw something like this up so hold on
I'm gonna send you a copy the book on
Trey leadership I want you to get into
business I want you to own your own
business but I want to be something you
love doing and you're making money not
just you're chasing the dollar chase a
dollar you'll never catch it
it'll smack you on both your ears hold
on I'll have Kelly pick up and I'll send
you copy the book I don't think I can
stop you though